no one gives about the beep well we do
but let's be real it's not the most
inspiring position one of my favorite
anecdotes about US politics is how when
President Dwight the Eisenhower was
asked which major White House decisions
his vice president was involved in and
he responded by saying if you give me a
week I might think of one that snark
gets to the heart of how the Vice
President has traditionally been seen an
uninvolved guy who's just there in case
the lead dude gets knocked out after all
the Constitution entrusts the vice
president with just two basic duties
first to oversee the Senate and vote if
there's any tie and two to take over the
presidency in case a president was
unable to carry out his or her duties
whatever the reason that's literally it
but who the Vice President is can be
critical to a presidential candidate
specifically when it comes to winning
the presidency and no contrary to
popular belief it's not about home state
advantage usually a presidential
candidate will pick a running-mate who
balances out his or her own political
experience so for example a state
governor may pick someone who's got
experience on the hill like governor
Mitt Romney picking representative paul
ryan as a running mate in the 2012
election cycle join me in welcoming the
next president of the united states paul
ryan and it's not just about where the
running mates had experience it's also
about what kind of experience like when
a candidate is weak on foreign policy
and hasn't been in the game that long in
2001 then governor george w bush picked
a White House veteran from his dad's
administration former Secretary of
Defense Dick Cheney President Barack
Obama's veep pick in 2008 followed a
similar although less aggressive
approach the senator from Chicago was
criticized for his lack of political
experience especially when it came to
foreign policy he only had four years of
experience at the federal level so it
makes sense when he brought in Senator
Joe Biden who not only had 26 years of
federal experience but an established
foreign policy track record something
Senator Obama just didn't have but what
about actually winning an election well
a vice president won't necessarily make
or break a presidential candidate
but the wrong pickin still hurt in 2008
governor Sarah Palin cost Senator John
McCain 1.2 million votes or about 1.6
percentage points on Election Day while
that percentage wouldn't have changed
the outcome of the election still a
significant loss so a running mate can
actually be pretty important for any
presidential candidate but with limited
responsibilities at home where an are
they after the election